and an ethical code would be a code that
laid down a series of behaviors that are
expressive of truth or reality that come
that that showed people how to behave in
line with or in a way that is consistent
with the fact that everyone shares their
being that all ethics can be boiled down
to that single bank official behavior is
behavior that is consistent with the
fact that we all share our being this is
why st. Augustine when asked about these
matters ethics and laws he simply said
love and do whatever you want he meant
simply realized that you are one with
everything and everyone and as long as
your behavior is consistent with that
understanding you don't need any moral
code that everything you do will be
consistent with that understanding the
reason why we need and ten commandments
or a moral code is because for those of
us that do not yet feel this we are we
are told how to behave in a way that is
consistent with this understand until we
realize it for our self so let's go back
to David in the symphony so the
violinist is you say in your analogy the
violinist is what is one who is is aware
of that she shares her yes reality yes
with everyone and the clarinetist
does not yet realize this he still
believes and feels that he is a
temporary finite self however I would
suggest that many artists and many
musicians
when they are in their studios or when
they are performing in their in their
quartets or their bands or their
orchestras that they are at least for
the duration for a period of time in
which they are performing they are they
their art they transcend yeah their
limitations as a person and they perform
in a way that is expressive of truth or
reality when they then go back to their
everyday lives they revert to believing
and feeling that they are a separate
self or an ego but many people in fact
this is why for some for many artists
them that their art is a kind of it's
it's it's not a compulsion it's
something that they they can't not do
that that they they know that when they
are in their studios or performing in
their orchestras or band they are in
touch with something that they know is
so utterly alive and true and in that
moment they do transcend the sense of
separation they are expressing the truth
reality love so it's not it's not black
and white it's not either you've
recognized yourself you know your true
nature and everything you do expresses
that or you haven't yet there is a
spectrum yes beautiful yes and he's not
only true sorry it's not only true of
artists it's true of everybody
yes exactly in that sense all a billion
are artists in that sense all a billion
of us know the experience of love in
other words everybody has tasted the
fact that we share our being and
everybody has had the experience of
behaving and relating in a way that is
consistent with that understanding for
most people it's only that behavior is
only directed towards a few people in
their circle their friends or their
family yes but nevertheless they've
still understood and felt what it is to
to share our being even if that is not
that consistent experience in Rupert
would you say that we are over the last
several thousand years if not tens of
thousands of years that we have been
going more and more towards the the
general general real the full embodied
realization more I hope so because
that's that's and that's the general
idea of what it like in evolution when
people say that word that's yeah I tend
to be optimistic
everything ultimately is destined to
return to its source there is nowhere
else for it to return to so ultimately
everything is destined for its source
one could argue that there is more more
violence more disharmony more conflict
in the world today I would suggest that
the old structures were in in our
society were egoic structures they were
structured corporations in our
governments in our institutions in us
they were structures that were based
upon an egoic sense of self as more than
ironical a separate self and that
expresses itself in extremes in
tyrannical dictatorships but also in
much smaller ways in in families in
companies in communities and that the
sense of separation can express itself
but so I would suggest that that then
the chaos we see in in our society today
and the violence the conflict I hope and
I believe that it is the evidence that
these structures are falling apart
because they're not based in truth or
reality and although we're witnessing a
time of great upheaval I hope that and I
believe that that it makes it makes it
for the possibility that a new order
will emerge one that is based on
yes I shared being it just must be that
is the single understanding exact like
we share our being when everyone and
everything must be the foundation of any
truly civilized culture it must be at
the origin of a civilized culture I love
that I love that that first principle of
recognition of shared being yeah it's
the principle that it should be the
fundamental principle of all but not
only of all of us but but but because
we're speaking of the world of all
politicians
yes exactly all politics should business
service of one idea or one understanding
alone namely everyone and everything
when I say everything I include
everything because I'm not just talking
about animals and people I'm talking
about the earth yes everyone and
everything share their being but that
should be the single guiding principle
of of all people in general but
politicians yes that their policies
their individual policies then in
relation to different to different
situations an event would would be the
means by which this understanding was
then expressed and shared and
communicated and implicated in society
yes we have been very obsessed about
taking that recognition of shared being
and having a deeply embodied at Davos at
the World Economic Forum in the global
500 top companies all the presidents and
congresses of the world in Hollywood in
Silicon Valley all these places
especially in people that have so much
guiding influence are the most important
especially to have that recognition of
shared being be that forceful and and
when it becomes the first principle
Rupert it also enables the recognition
that my clarinet or violin or saxophone
or drums or bass or whatever I'm
doing it must be for the the the service
other it must be for augmenting the
social fabric for enabling the basic
needs on like Maslow's hierarchy to be
met so that if air water food energy
education healthcare etc are met it
enables people to have a deeper self
abidance it enables the inquiry into the
true nature of reality plus it enables
them to become an artist in symphony as
well and so that's sort of the general
process that at least I see one who is
one who not only understands but feel
that they share their being with
everyone and everything they play in
tune in the symphony and one who does
not feel this plays out of tune out of
tune china hoard materialistic
possessions and that type of stuff that
that versus playing in tune I like that
I like that as well that's so so
excellent